Howard Stern is out I kind of felt like  it was enough for me Simon Cowell is in  the American Idol judge is returning to  us TV as the new judge of America's Got  Talent  a show he created did you say I would  like to be the judge or was it someone  else's decision so haha no I couldn't  repeat it to that it was the network's  decision Simon will join returning  judges Howie Mandel Heidi Klum and Mel B  next summer  I think the America's Got Talent Show  honestly one of the best camera shows in  the world I mean I watch it back and in  front of all this is a really good show  the British one has been probably the  most fun job I've ever had in my life